[Music]
I learned about nine causes of
depression anxiety for which there's
scientific evidence which opens up all
different solutions so I'll just give
you a quick example of one I notice the
lots of people I know who are depressed
and anxious that depression and anxiety
focuses around their work so I start
looking at well how do people feel about
their work what's going on here Gallup
did the most detailed study that's ever
been done on this what they found is 13%
of us liked our work most of the time
63% of us are what they called
sleepwalking through our work we don't
like it we don't hate it we tolerate it
24% of us hate our jobs do you think
about that 87% of people in our culture
don't like the thing they're doing most
of the time they did send their first
work email at 7:48 a.m. and clock off at
7:15 p.m. on average most of us don't
want to be doing it could this have a
relationship to our mental health I
started looking for the best evidence on
its own I discovered an amazing
Australian social scientist called
Michael Marmot who I got to know who
discovered in the story of how I
discovered it's amazing but I'll give
you the headline he discovered the key
factor that makes us depressed and
anxious at work if you go to work and
you feel controlled you feel you have
few or limited choices you are
significantly more likely to become
depressed or actually even more likely
to have a stress-related heart attack
and this is because of one of the things
that connects so many of the causes of
depression and anxiety I learned about
everyone watching this knows that you
have natural physical needs right you
need food you need water you need
shelter you need clear now if I took
them away from you you would be in
trouble real fast right
there's equally strong evidence that we
have natural psychological needs you've
got to feel you belong you've got to
feel your life has meaning and purpose
you've got to feel that people see you
and value you you've got to feel you've
got a future that makes sense and if
human beings are deprived of those
psychological needs they will experience
extreme forms of distress our culture is
good at lots of things we're getting
less and less good at meeting people's
deep underlying psychological needs and
this is one of the key factors where
depression is rising and that opens just
to finish the point about work that
opens up a very different way of
thinking about how we solve these
problems right so if control at work is
driving is one of the drivers of this
depression anxiety a bit
so I think well what would be an
antidepressant for that right what would
solve that in Baltimore I met a woman
called Meredith Keough is part of an
amazing transformation
Meredith used to go to bed every Sunday
night just sick with anxiety she had an
office job it wasn't the worst office
job in the world she wasn't think bully
but but she couldn't bear the thought
that this monotony was going to be the
next 40 years of her life most of her
life and one day Meredith did an
experiment with her husband Josh Josh
had worked in bike stores since he was a
teenager
again it's insecure controlled workers
you can imagine and one day Josh and his
friends in the bike store just ask
themselves what what does a boss
actually do they liked their boss he
wasn't particularly bad guy but they
thought well we fix all the bikes they
didn't like this feeling of having a
boss they decided to do something
different so Meredith quit her job Josh
and his friends quit their jobs they set
up a bike store that works on a
different older principle it's a
democratic cooperative not a corporation
so the way it works is there is no boss
they take the decisions together
democratically by voting they share out
the good tasks and the bad tasks they
share the profits and one of the things
that was so interesting to me going
there which is completely in line with
Professor marmots findings is how many
of them talked about how depressed and
anxious they've been when they worked in
a controlled environment and they
weren't depressed and anxious now now
it's important to say it's not like they
quit their jobs fixing bikes and went to
become like Beyonce's backing singers
right they fix bikes before they fix
bikes now but they dealt with the factor
that causes depression and anxiety as
Josh put it to me there's no reason why
any business should be run in this
top-down depressogenic humiliating way
right the modern corporation is a very
recent invention think about how many
people you know who feel terrible today
who if they were going into work
tomorrow
to a workplace that they controlled with
their colleagues what if there had to be
a boss they elected the boss and the
boss was accountable to them where they
chose the priorities for their workplace
a lot of people would feel very
differently now that is an
antidepressant
right chemical antidepressant should
absolutely remain on the menu they give
some relief to some people that's
valuable but we need to look for
antidepressants that deal with the
reasons why we're depressed so I was
able to identify nine causes of
depression anxiety and seven
antidepressants like this which are
actually about dealing with the reasons
why we feel this way and
not just blunting the symptoms
[Music]